And with the death thing, I don't know.
I just look at life and I'm just like,
man, it's crazy. Like all of this stuff
here, believe it or not, is a big
distraction. Everything that I chase and
everything that I want to own to make me
feel relevant on this earth is not so
important.
>> It is a wakeup call to him to be like
this. Dun is nothing. And you have to I
don't know if you accepted Islam or not,
bro. Wallah, if that was me, the first
thing I would do is like shahada, bro.
When I became Muslim, I wanted to pray,
but I didn't know how.
>> And they were now guided salam mats
[music] to help me either.
>> That's why these guided salamats are so
powerful.
>> They teach you how to pray step by step.
>> For just £10, you can help up to three
people to [music] learn how to pray.
>> But for £100,
>> you can guide by the will of Allah.
[music]
>> 10 to 30 people connect with Allah every
single day. Imagine the reward for every
prayer they make,
>> every faj, every dur, every [music]
assur, every m, every isha, every salah
they make is on your scale.
>> Donate now and help someone [music]
stand in prayer today.
>> Brothers and sisters, dear friends, hope
you guys are well inshallah. I'm here
with brother Canyon.
>> Yeah. Alhamdulillah. Uh, so obviously I
don't know. I think was you with us in
the car when we first heard about the
death of brother Abdul Latif.
>> Obviously that he's someone that you
don't know. I don't think you've met
him.
>> You do know Anthony Joshua.
>> Yeah.
>> So he was close with Anthony Joshua. He
was his friend. If I'm not mistaken he
was even giving him dawa.
>> So he's a brother that I've met once in
near my area in in a masjid. I can
remember he was in a restaurant and
that's one time and I've met him a
couple of times before as well. um few
brother um a so what was your take
because there's the initial news of the
accident
>> and sadly a lot of people obviously just
were just talking about Anthony Joshua
>> yeah there were two other souls there
who were in there as well and obviously
we're happy that Anthony Joshua
>> um survived it but um what was your take
like when you first where did you hear
it first did you hear it when waswan
told us
>> yeah yeah that's what I heard first I
think obviously first off for the Muslim
brothers may Allah have mercy on them
and
>> um get high freaking agenda and be
rewarded for all the good that they did
while they're on this earth. I mean, um,
for me, I think it's just, you know,
it's a sad but much needed reminder of
how fleeting life is, right? We're in
this society right now where if our food
wasn't amazing or if I if our shoes
don't fit exactly perfect, we complain
about all these things and, oh, this
sucks. My life sucks. When in the
reality, today could be your last day
alive. And you're going to tell me
you're going to spend your last day
alive complaining that your food wasn't
good or your food was late. Um, I think
it's a it's a much needed reminder of of
life and how it can just be gone like
that. And then the next part is, you
know, with Anthony Joshua, he just won a
fight, you know, top of the top of the
world, has all this money. And then you
have something like that happen. It's
another reminder where all of these
things that we attach ourselves to these
these dunya materials, all my money, my
status, my fame, that can also just be
gone instantaneously. And I think it's
really important for us to stay grounded
and remember truly what's important
because we're not going to be here very
long.
>> Yeah. Like to me there was a couple of
things that hit me like when I
>> when I heard this and I I got to saw a
horrific footage um that was circulating
which I'll be honest you there's there's
hearing that the brothers passed away
which is sad in itself.
>> Then seeing the footage which I cannot
even describe to you bro I was in his
close friend
Show you the streets of Nigeria.
Olina
And that like when I saw that and I'm
someone I would say that I remember
death often. Yeah. I try to because I
come from a jah I come from the dunya
the money the cars the all that kind of
stuff. I've left that behind. And even
then, it hit me. So, like in a way where
I was like, man, like imagine you just
have all these plans and I'm going to do
this and I'm going to move into this new
house and I'm going to buy a new car or
I'm planning on doing this with my wife
or I'm planning do going here with my
children. I'm planning on doing this.
You've got these plans, plans, plans.
And it's who is your Lord?
Who is your Lord? Who was your prophet?
What was your religion? It's like going
from that to that because that was
instant death. Like what what I saw that
I cannot even describe to you. That was
number one. Number one just showed me
like how just just like that you're gone
and like you said complain about [music]
the most stupid silly things in life
that people argue, complain, fall out
with each other about. And it was like
all over what to a death. Like they said
the the causes are many but the death is
one. It's the same death. The causes are
many. Number two for AJ and I believe
this video will reach from Anthony
Joshua.
Abdul Latif was someone who gave you
dawa, who told you about Islam. You
prayed behind him. Obviously, we do not
know if you're a Muslim or not, but
brother Abdah to you. May Allah bless
and preserve him and allow in this in
the hereafter and that allow it to bear
for him because he's put that effort in.
Subhan Allah. He was into his fitness,
you know, subhan Allah. He did many
stuff, etc., etc. He went to um Gambia
with brother Abu Bakr, subhan Allah, for
the spot project. Um, and there's even a
link in the description. I'm going to
put two links there to do a number one,
the water whales and other stuff that's
brother uh Abu Bakr doing number two for
our salah pro project because it's a
ongoing for him to teach people how to
pray salah. If you want to donate to
that, it's those two links are there
because I really wanted him to benefit
in his hereafter. Inshallah water wells
are fantastic and also to teach someone
how to pray salah and continues and
continues that we hope Abd our brother
will see that on the amount of people
that he helped be it water wells be it
to the orphans be it teaching people how
to pray Allah subhanana which is so
close to my heart so that was one and
for AJ wall that's this this if this is
not a wakeup call I don't know what is
because it is it was so horrifying for
me to for him to be in that scene
knowing that's happened to find out his
friends died. Subhan Allah. It is a
wakeup call to him to be like this. Duma
is nothing and you have to I don't know
if you accepted Islam or not. Bro, if
that was me, the first thing I would do
is like shahada, bro. Like like I'm just
like this is a sign within itself. He
and somebody else survived.
>> Yeah. So, subh to me that was like a
massive wakeup call.
>> And with the death thing, I don't know.
I just look at life and I'm just like,
man, it's crazy. Like all of this stuff
here, believe it or not, is a big
distraction in my opinion because in the
grand scheme of things, like everything
that I chase and everything that I want
to own to make me feel relevant on this
earth is not so important because I
can't take it with me. That's what's
guaranteed is is death.
>> All that's going to be important is kind
of like just living to the best of our
capability. [music] It matter how fast
life will go. will be old and one day
all that will matter is living to the
best of our capability.
>> And lastly, I would say that Allah tells
us in the Quran
Allah says you are busy with the worldly
affairs,
>> with a worldly competition. Yes. What I
have, what I drive, who sees me, this,
etc. Until you visit the graves. Allah
says until you visit the graves, you're
busy with all of this stuff. Until you
visit the graves and know surely you're
going to know. And Allah repeats a
statement and says, "And know surely you
will know." Allah has given you a
promise that the hereafter is real.
Allah is telling you, you are busy with
all of this glamour, all of these things
that agent lives as well. Yeah. Until
you visit the graves. And the scholars,
the understand this in two ways. Number
one, you go and bury someone.
>> So those who are going to go to the
brother's janaza,
>> they're going to go there and be like,
"Wow, I'm chasing the dunya and this
that whatever."
>> But this is the reality. And number two,
the scholars say is not someone being
alive and burying someone, but rather
you yourself die. Meaning Allah saying
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you die and enter the grave, then
everything stops.
>> So, subhan Allah, it's it's such a such
a powerful line to us. And one thing
that is I want to touch on cuz I I don't
like to be fake. Yeah. Like we heard of
the death and like it was upset, etc.
But our life continued, bro. Let's be
real, bro. Our life continued. Like even
5 10 minutes ago, we was making jokes.
>> Yeah. Not that we're not silent to what
happened. This is the reality of the
dunya, bro. When I die, my friends might
be sad for couple of hours. If anything,
somebody's going to make a joke and
someone's going to laugh. And that
reality is a reality to tell you, even
your own mother, after a couple of
months time, somebody's going to make a
joke and she's going to laugh. That
doesn't make her bad. That is the
reality of the dunya we are living.
Which shows you what?
No one will ever be there for you truly
except the one who created you. And if
you put him first, you will see him
first inshallah.
>> That was my reflections on this.
>> Yeah.
>> I think it's also a very sobering
thought for uh all Muslims right now. If
you were to die right now, are you in a
place where you feel like
>> you're ready to face your Lord? Right?
Have you have Have you conquered that
sin? Have you dealt with that issue?
Right? A lot of people we procrastinate.
I I'll I'll deal with it later. Right?
Oh, no, no, no. in a year I'll start
praying five times a day. No, no. In a
year I'll get out of this haram
relationship. You might not have a year,
right? You might die right now and you
face Allah right now. Would how would
you feel facing Allah right now with the
sins that you're dealing with and you
haven't yet repented, right? So, I think
it's a very sobering thought and
something we as Muslims need to
understand where it's like every single
day could be your last day and you
should be prepared every day to meet
your Lord. Am I in a state to meet my
Lord? Am I in a place right where I am
right now? If I died right now, is this
a fine place to die? Right? It's like a
you're at the club, you're um in a place
you shouldn't be and then you die.
That's where you die.
>> Exactly. And just lastly, you know that
yolo, you only live once. We also live
by that. And also the people who are who
follow that lifestyle of do have fun as
much as you like. The difference is
this. They say, "I'm going to live once.
Let me have as as much fun as I can."
The believer says, "I'm going to live
once. Let me do as much good deeds as I
can." So it's both yolo. You only live
once. It's the perspective of how we see
it. So again, I want to reiterate guys,
everyone has plans. Cars, holidays,
this, I'm going here. And you know what
the funny thing is? We book these things
and think of these plans as if they are
promised to us. As if I'm like 100% for
certainty, I'm going to do this. And
just imagine this guys, all of these
plans that we all have, every single one
of us here.
Next minute, it's who is your Lord from
the angels. It went from that to plans
to that and my career whatever it is to
split moment of death and you wake up in
your grave and the question is asked you
who is your Lord are you ready to answer
that and Allah says we will make them
firm they shall not grieve nor shall
they fear Allah has given you that
promise you will not grieve nor you
shall fear and you will only have that
is if you live and die by illallah if
you don't live by you are not going to
die by and in that grave you are not
going to be able to answer it no matter
how much you memorized it. So make dua
for our brother. May Allah grant him the
highest ranks of Jenna for the da that
he's given to brother AJ. And inshallah
we don't know if he's accepted Islam or
not. Hopefully this is a sign that it
will and number two there's for both
things spot project and for the salah
project inshallah bro sisters which goes
towards teaching people how to pray
salah and do it with intentions of on
behalf of this brother and those who
have passed away. Till next time.